thank you so much for joining us today
welcome to the rstudio enterprise
community meetup
i'm rachel i'm actually calling in from
san diego today so more of a morning
meetup for me
we're streaming out to linkedin and
youtube right now so i'd love to have
you all introduce yourselves and where
you're calling in from in the chat
i'm excited to have matt miller here
with us today for part two of our
functional data analysis meetup series
a big thank you to santiago who kicked
off the intro to fda
meetup initially as well
i'll share the link to that recording
too so you have it as well
if this is your first time joining one
of these sessions welcome we're so glad
to have you here
this is a friendly meetup environment
for teams to share use cases teach
lessons learned and
just meet each other and ask questions
i just wanted to say this as well while
it's called the enterprise community
meetup this is open to everyone
regardless of where you work and the
tools that you use
i created this group as the enterprise
meetup so that it would be okay for us
to occasionally talk about the rstudio
professional products like pursue
workbench and connect
but everybody is welcome
together we are all dedicated to making
this an inclusive and open environment
for everyone
no matter your experience industry or
background
i'll share a link in the chat where you
can find out about other upcoming events
too
also during the event you are able to
ask questions you can ask them through
the chat if you're on linkedin and
youtube it will
gather them for me and you can also ask
questions anonymously through slido
and you can just use the link that i'll
show on the screen here in just a second
to be able to ask questions anonymously
as well
with that said i would love to introduce
our speaker for today here let me put a
side by side
there we go
awesome so i'm so happy to be joined by
matt here matt is an associate research
data scientist supporting new product
development within the packaging and
specialty plastics business at the dow
chemical company
and uh matt and i actually met through
santiago's fda meetup
which was your first meetup i think
right awesome i wanted to share that too
just to say if there's ever a topic or
use case that you all would like to
highlight from your team we'd love to
hear from you too so if you ever even
want to just float an idea by me please
feel free to connect on linkedin or or
email email me too it's just rachel
rstudio.com
but i'll share my linkedin in the chat
as well
okay that's enough for me i'm done thank
you again again matt i would love to
turn it over to you and i'll pull your
slides up here
awesome thanks rachel for the
introduction thank you all for for
joining uh
i'm excited for this opportunity to just
continue the the discussion on
functional data so
during i think it was in march with
santiago's meetup the q a session two
topics came up functional pca principal
components analysis and functional
regression uh both of which that i've
applied in various projects at dao and
so that's why connecting with rachel who
said all right let's uh
let's go for uh
part two of the series and hence we're
here today
so i've broken this this talk in general
into i guess four major sections sort of
an introduction both of myself and just
kind of a quick refresher on functional
data functional data analysis
and kind of introduced our simulated
case study that we'll we'll walk through
and the questions we want to solve using
functional data methods
then second
again it'll kind of be a refresher with
some data pre-processing steps for fda
so particularly smoothing with penalized
splines to create the the true
functional observations that we want to
analyze
um and then again the two topics uh
topics due to our functional pca which
will help us answer the first question
about clustering different additives or
experimental materials
based on decay curves that we see for
measuring a material characteristic and
then functional regression so then
taking
those characteristic profiles to predict
uh an application performance
um and i think it'll be important in
that section as well to kind of compare
to
traditional or
other methods that we might use to
analyze such data given various
limitations we'll talk about as well as
just the
uh
a tall versus a wide data matrix and
last of course just some summary and
takeaways
so quickly about myself so i'm i'm
native to michigan which global
headquarters for dao is in midland
michigan uh but i actually work in our
texas location and you'll see why here
in a second
so uh metro detroit is where i was uh
born and raised i didn't travel very far
to do my first two degrees so grand
valley state university is located in
the
western side of the lower peninsula just
outside of grand rapids michigan so i
did my bachelor's in stat and masters in
biostat and even though the masters
program is a technically a terminal
degree for most i still wanted to learn
more
um i also realized that i wasn't a fan
of cold and winter so i came south where
i've still been so i went to texas a m
university for my phd which is also a
connection with santiago as he was also
an aggie
in
my phd research was kind of a grab bag
of a bunch of topics so bayesian
non-parametric goodness of fit testing
using cross validation base factors it's
essentially the use of
kernel density estimators for an
alternative
to
for our alternative
hypothesis
in multivariate goodness-of-fit testing
like testing multivariate normality and
it required some uh data splitting and
dividing conquer type techniques for
cross-validation
uh so for those interested so i'll throw
in a shameless plug uh
one chapter of that work is is published
in international statistical review
um for those interested in checking it
out so after graduation i
uh
came from went from college station to
lake jackson texas just south of houston
where
most okay so i'm coming up on my
five-year work adversary um
but
all but like two months of time i was a
statistician within core r d so
supporting global r d at dao
in any and all statistical needs
primarily in experimental design
and just recently i
took the role that i'm in in as a data
scientist in packaging and specialty
plastics
and that was a natural transition
because i was my primary focal point was
the plastics business so it was just
taking a step to do more uh projects
within the business
my general
specialty areas especially at dao so
hence today functional data analysis is
probably my main area at dao
in addition to non-parametrics and
statistical computing or simulation
project applications also related to the
case study we'll talk about today is a
polymer or new product resin design
using some machine learning models or
computational methods as well as then
development of sustainable products
which is a big push in the industry
today especially with the plastics
business
so
let's quickly recap or review
functional data and functional data
analysis
so we're all familiar with the two major
types of variables continuous
categorical or
our usual scalar approaches
functional variables are where we can't
use a single value or we don't have a
single value to measure
the
characteristic of interest that variable
for an experimental unit so we actually
have an entire process a distribution or
a curve
and so we want to be able to
have a class of methods that allow us to
analyze functional variables and here's
some examples these are all available in
the fda package which all stem from
ramsey and silverman who are sort of the
the original bible i guess of functional
data analysis is the book of the same
title
published in the i guess first time in
the in the mid 1990s
so these examples you can find this data
within that packaging are
and
common examples so top left
growth curves so those of you who have
children or remember going to
the pediatrician as a child right
there's
unequally spaced milestone visits but we
want to track how individuals grow from
birth all the way till 18 years
so for each person they have an entire
growth curve
the canadian weather data which if you
recall santiago talked about quite a bit
so
for
i think it's 35 weather stations in
canada we're looking at the temperature
profile
across an entire year for each of those
cities and trying to analyze how do the
profiles differ say based on region in
canada
functional data can be two-dimensional
or multi-dimensional so an example is
writing on an electronic pad the letters
fda and cursive multiple times so you
have this also spatial orientation so
it's not required it's rescaled to time
but you know it's it's also you're not
required to have time say as your only
dimension
or your
your domain for your functional
observation
and lastly something that looks like
distributional data which you can see
maybe some challenges in analyzing this
as it's it has to do with pinching your
thumb with your forefinger and the the
force exerted
and so you can see that there's
different time points at which the force
starts and the peak force occurs at
different
different time uh values in the interval
from 0 to 0.3 seconds
plus it has a different height as well
so it's shifted as well as scaled
so we won't talk about it today but
registration and alignment as another
pre-processing is very important for for
data like this say maybe peak aligning
is something you might look at
now for
analyzing functional data there are many
of the methods that are just analogs to
traditional scalar approaches
two which are sort of more unique to
functional
well curve estimation or smoothing
certainly you need more than one point
uh to
smooth a curve uh so
that's that's a pre-processing step that
we'll we'll look at
i think one interesting one is the
analysis of derivatives so for growth
curves you could look at acceleration
functions
because you've now
got a smooth and continuous
variable observation that you can take
derivatives uh for so you get functions
derivative functions as opposed to just
rise over run calculations
um
for the the functional analogs just so
within exploratory data analysis means
variances correlations you can compute
all of those
you can do principal components analysis
linear or generalized linear models and
you can even do functional experimental
design and many of these are related but
i think we'll see just natural
extensions of
methods that we know and love to
apply them to functional observations
so to sort of motivate you know use
cases for uh fda so this is our case
study data that we'll talk about now
it's uh it is simulated and in the link
that uh rachel i think sent out or will
send out
i've made the slides as well as my code
available so every analysis every
picture that you see
including all the seeds is available to
explore and you'll be able to reproduce
everything
but for this example
we have 41 different additives different
experimental materials one of which is a
standard you can think of standard as a
it could be the gold standard on the
market it could be a control it could be
just a theoretical target that you want
to hit so that's the solid black but the
further study on 41 different additives
could be resource intensive so the idea
one of the questions we'll look at is is
how can we quickly select
profiles or new materials for further
study that are most similar to this
standard
now
it
this material characteristic it's
measured over 24 hours
but it resembles exponential decay
and so as we might often see especially
with like decay functions that this the
time points at which we measure are
unequally spaced so it starts out
condensed that you know uh time zero
which they all started a hundred so time
one two then it goes every two hours
till eight then every four hours till
24. so they're unequally spaced time
points and also in the example that that
we had
based on the
data processing to actually create these
profiles we actually had a lot of
missing data so not all that actually
rarely did we have all 10 points
so we had on
on somewhere between five and eight
points for each curve so each
observation each material had unequally
spaced points and a differing number of
points
so the first question that we'll ask and
try to answer and this will be used with
the functional pca is can we pick three
to five experimental materials that are
top candidates for further study
and second
this material characteristic this
profile
is strongly related to application
performance so as we try to create and
design new materials
we'd say okay from this profile we we'd
also want to know
uh which ones to look at based on
predicting performance in the final
application and that's where we'll look
at functional regression
now you might think there's
we've seen pictures like this
you know quite often
for
some traditional analyses so some things
that we might use maybe to not answer
these exact questions but to analyze
this data is you could use time series
repeated measures longitudinal data
analysis all sort of similar flavor they
answer different questions of course
but
we could do moment-based regression so
try to summarize
these
profiles into some set of scalar moments
and then just apply
like typical linear models
or we could do a multivariate approach
so pca or pls say if we had multiple
correlated responses and so we'd
actually analyze the data matrix formed
here
but each of these have some limitations
so particularly a time series repeated
measures typically you require equally
spaced time points and the same number
of points for each curve so a consistent
domain for the discrete measurements
for moments we know in dimension
reduction typically we lose information
so that's always a
kind of a pro and con it's easier to
analyze but we do suffer information
loss
and methods like multivariate so the pca
pls well that looks at data matrix which
kind of ignores the functional
relationship between the successive
columns and in fact with pls it's it's
known right that if you permute the
columns of your data matrix you're going
to get the same model in the end so that
functional relationship is is uh
essentially uh destroyed and are not
captured in these multivariate
approaches but fda methods allow us to
alleviate or basically uh
remove many of these limitations
so i'll pause here for
i guess any quick uh questions just
about the
what is functional data or the the case
study
i don't see any over on the slido yet
but just wanted to
remind everyone if you do want to ask
questions anonymously you can do so
using slido and i just put the
link in the chat
i'll pull it up here on the screen again
too and there will be more pauses too so
if there's none now and they come up as
you as we go we can always we can always
answer questions about the topics uh
kind of retroactively
sounds good
sounds good we'll wait till the next
question break then okay
so
and once you
have measured your functional
observations i think what you've noticed
is that it's not truly a smooth
continuous function that we're analyzing
because we we never actually observe
this true process because we measure it
at set time points or points in the
domain it's always a discretized
function so that's why smoothing is
often the first step of pre-processing
and and in many cases it can be a
requirement for
like pca or full functional pca
so
why do we have to do this well again
with a discrete curve so x is actually
our true process that we want to explore
but we actually observe why
because when we go to measure the points
we try to measure at different tj's
the value of this process there's error
likely involved measure measurement
error process error
and so we don't observe the true process
we observe something with error that we
need to
uh convert to our our functional
observation to analyze
and so that you know the common
approaches are penalized splines in some
fashion fourier series for periodic data
cubic b splines or some other uh
regression spline for non-periodic data
we play with the bias variance trade-off
with a smoothing parameter lambda
and
an important note is that you could do
this all at once
so you could take all your observations
smooth them all together or you can
actually you know treat them and do them
individually which
we'll see we have to do in our case
and just to give an example of this uh
the penalization and smoothing here so
i've generated from the sine function
some points so the gray
the gray circles i think it's 100 or
maybe 200 points
within the domain minus three to three
it equally spaced so you see that there
is a a process underlying this there is
a
functional relationship across these
points but we don't have a great uh
we wouldn't want to connect these points
so how do we actually estimate the true
function the black curve
so if we pick a lambda that's too small
we under smooth and as it approaches
zero you basically interpolate the
points so you have high variance low low
bias
so we probably wouldn't want to use that
that red curve
green if we pick a lambda too big we
over smooth so we actually typically
will miss valleys and peaks which you
observe here so here we have very low
variance
but high bias so the best is
you know we can pick this through trial
and error or some cross-validation
technique but
when you have a an appropriately
smoothed
function with fourier series you see
it's actually hard to discern the blue
dashed line compared to black which
tells us that see we were able to use
splines to capture our true
the underlying process here
now how does this apply to
our case study data
so remember we do have the unequally
spaced then differing number of points
so we'll do it individually one at a
time remember we only have five to eight
measurements but because of using the
penalized splines we can have great
flexibility with
20
cubic b splines so we actually have you
know like four times as many splines as
we do points uh but we can still
estimate the the function we do it one
at a time and then re-evaluate to
basically form a consistent data matrix
so we fit the smooth evaluate it at
every hour time point stack them all
together you get a 41 by 25 matrix
where row per row each row is is a
experimental material
and then eventually we'll kind of
re-smooth or reapply uh the same
smoothing to create a functional data
object with all 41 curves so it's kind
of like two different sets of smoothing
and if you check out the code you'll
kind of see how this works
but we need that functional data object
for later use and how well does this
work so here's the ample for the the
standard
so the discrete curve is actually the
dashed red
applying these splines and reevaluating
and plotting you can see that even with
only i forget how many we have on the
standard five to eight points
the smooth can actually estimate
that true
or our underlying process very well
and we apply the same approach to all
the curves and i think you can see that
we do reasonably well
at capturing just the the overall shape
of each of those individual profiles
so now the question becomes how do we
address the two questions
so i guess a short section if there are
any questions we can
we can take them on the first two topics
one question that was on slido was
what made you first interested in fda
ah great question i didn't i didn't
cover it in the uh bio so
before
one of the elective courses at a m was
um i forget the number it's not
important um non-parametric curve
estimation
and because of where my research was
heading it was a an elective that my
advisor said i should take
and so in that class the professor
taught us fda
so it just was one of those kind of like
you know happy accidents that my advisor
had the project and said take this class
and we did fda so actually
and a part of that class was a project
that you had to implement all of the
methods and so i did a study of
statehood obesity curves so actually
growth curves to look at what are the
important factors that would relate to
uh like statehood obesity and test out
hypotheses about
you know uh
uh socioeconomic status or
uh other information from demographics
thank you
a question i had actually is
what's a good way if like we're just
learning about this right now what's a
good way for us to know a project
could use fda analysis
yeah so i think it's
there are some more like natural
scenarios where it's just like
when you have one
experimental unit
one thing in your study that's got a
measurement that's like i have an entire
distribution
i have like where you know it's not a
single value so there might be an
underlying uh
uh
like you you know that uh
so like a molecular weight distribution
we know that there's not just one
polymer chain of constant length so you
have to actually look at like
chromatographic data in uh
analytical uh science or different
characterization groups you know this is
something that
you
use the same type of methods you just
know you're going to get a distribution
or if you're looking at growth or decay
functions like you just
it kind of just naturally you ask the
question can i represent this as one
number or do i need all of these values
and
of course you know it's like two
dimensional or more they're they might
be more difficult but you know it's
usually like
you have something measured over time
and space
and it's hard to summarize it as one
single value
that's really helpful thank you
i see
that we have a question in the chat as
well and it was actually santiago he
said hi matt santiago great job so far
by the way what is your decision
framework for which basis function
cubic for you can read it there yeah so
yeah that that is a good question uh i
think you know the the first okay so
it's like a tree diagram the first one
you look at is okay do i have periodic
or non-periodic data periodic meaning
that my
so if i look at the function the far
left point and the far right point
should be the same so like the
temperature profile is an example where
december 31st and january 1st are far
more related even though they're at the
opposite ends of the of the domain so
those temperatures should probably be
close to each other um and so then then
you'd use fourier series um cubic beast
blinds i think that's just a good
default i know there's some theory out
there um
like uh it comes from deboer that says
cubic b splines with a knot at each data
point is the best you can select
um
i think it's more so like you could use
wavelets as an example for when you have
uh really peaked functions
um and so yeah like there's a response
that i saw it really depends on what
you're
what you're trying uh depends on what
you the data you have and what you're
trying to do because if you think like
take a uh
some
normal distribution which kind of looks
like some of the basis functions in the
interior and you try and have a really
peaked function
so like like gc mass spec data which is
very peaked well you're going to always
underestimate that because the normal
just can't get all the way up to a like
an absolute value looking function but
wavelets have that ability
so it really based on the context and
and what you observe
with the data but a foreshadowing answer
is that sometimes you can actually use
your data to define basis functions for
later use
and that you'll see in fpca here
awesome can i ask you one more question
okay i see
that
ravinder put a question to the youtube
chat
great question is functional data
analysis related to functional
programming
i actually don't know the answer to that
one i'm not familiar with functional
programming um
so i guess
maybe i i'll ask help from anyone else
on the line that might know enough about
functional programming i just
yeah definitely familiar so i won't even
take a stab
[Laughter]
and feel free to um
anybody who's listening to comment in
the chat or share links that have been
helpful for you and learning as well
i love getting to see the conversation
that happens there in the chat too
but thanks matt i will go backstage
all right
so to the first question
remember we want to identify
three to five
uh
three to five values or or experimental
materials most similar to the control
so to do that we're gonna use functional
pca now i mentioned that their
functional methods are often analogs of
traditional so a quick
three bullet point review here on
traditional pca so we have a data matrix
many columns
likely correlated
so
pca first is this is a data
transformation it's a rotation to
convert those correlated columns into
uncorrelated linear combinations of
those original vectors
and we can then do dimension reduction
because the rotation is such that the
first
principal component explains the most
variation
followed by
the
followed by the next most important
uncorrelated to the first and and onward
so oftentimes we can take many
dimensions and reduce them down into
one two or three that explain you know
90 or 95 percent of the total
variability in the system
mathematically to do this it's an eigen
analysis you compute the eigenvalues for
to get your pc scores and the
eigenvectors define our
our linear combinations and we do this
on either the covariance or correlation
matrix so what is functional pca
well mathematically i guess i'm going
out of order here we also still perform
an eigen analysis but this time on the
functions
uh
so slightly more complex but the same
general approach
we still capture the primary modes of
variation in successive order first
second third
but now the
functional pcs are orthonormal functions
so similar properties to what we get in
the linear combinations in traditional
pca
now i think this is the i think one of
the
interesting additional pieces that we
that we get from functional pca is this
idea of empirical basis functions
so carhoon and loev have this expansion
and basically what it says is that any
functional observation in our set our
sample
can be written as the mean function of
the sample
plus
a weighted sum of the
functional pc's our new building
production that i think is pretty
powerful
i think i lost your audio for a second
but that maybe was on my end i just want
to confirm that everybody can hear matt
okay
am i
nope you sound fine to me now so maybe
it was just a glitch
okay
so let's let's actually apply this to
our
our um
our case study data
so
um
it seems like it was just the last 30
seconds that we maybe lost you from yeah
i'll go back to the expansion um
so
okay why this this
carhoon and loev expansion this actually
gives us our empirical basis functions
so we can we can use our sample data to
make new building blocks which are these
empirical basis functions so what it
says is that
any sample in our
any functional observation in our sample
can be written as the overall
mean function
y bar of t
plus
a weighted sum
of the functional pcs so we have the pc
functions the xcs
times coefficients which start
originally as your pc scores for the
actual observations we observe so what
does this look like
for our case study data we have the
overall mean function which resembles
you know our typical exponential decay
for all of our samples
and we get two pc functions
first one explains 96 and a half percent
the second three percent so in two pcs
we basically capture all of the
variability 99.5 percent
um
they're not the easiest to interpret but
we'll see in the next slide that we can
get a picture that makes them easier to
interpret another bonus over traditional
pca often those linear combinations are
difficult to interpret in context but we
can actually get an idea of what these
pc functions
look like and how they contribute to our
our the different functions we observe
in our sample
and we can still get a score plot we
have two dimensions so we actually see
that
they're not we don't see just a random
scatter here we see a
kind of a parabolic shape
but they are uncorrelated with each
other and so now just thinking about how
we might solve the question with typical
pca i think we can already see that we
have pc scores in two dimensions maybe
we just perform simple clustering to
solve our question
now before we get there so this
interpretation idea so this if you
create a functional object in r that's a
result of functional pca
and you just plot it you just use base
plot function
you'll get this this picture by default
and it really helps with interpretation
because those pc functions are
essentially
perturbations
of the mean
so what does that mean
take pc one here on the left panel
the solid
line in each picture is the overall mean
curve
then it takes so the line defined by
pluses is a positive coefficient
multiplied by pc1 added to the mean
function so it says for a positive pc
one score
you would expect the shape to change
in that way so it becomes sort of like
an increase with a slower decay a
negative value of the same magnitude
gives you the minus line
so it basically tells us that
okay the difference in these three
curves really is in the first half of
time the relative steepness
of the initial 10 to 12 hours because
essentially after that point the lines
are
roughly parallel
pc2 remember is uncorrelated to pc1
so it would make sense that we basically
have regardless of that magnitude
there's no change or minimal change in
the first half of time so pc2 actually
explains the relative
decay the steepness the slope of that
decay in the second half of time
so this is actually really
sort of powerful just to get an idea of
of how
those pc functions relate to your
overall data as a function of that like
expansion
it's pretty interesting and it can it
can really help to explain the scenario
i think
as dimension reduction
so let's also look at these building
blocks to show you know so how you could
actually
um
so okay once you do fpca and you define
those pc functions they're fixed they're
known that's why you can use them as
basis functions the only thing that you
and the mean function is also known
right so the only thing in that carhoon
and low f expansion that that changes
now are scalar coefficients
so that that can be pretty powerful for
just dimension reduction because curves
are
more complex more
degrees of freedom to change those
shapes compared to just say two
coefficients here
so
how this works
we can basically
generate
new scores to look at the intuition of
okay how if i change the coefficient how
does the resulting function shape change
so i've just plotted again the two pc
functions they look pretty flat because
the scale has changed and i'll just
generate
new
pairs of scores so this one's about 50
and minus 25 for x and y
so 50 times blue gives me my dashed blue
minus 25 times red gives me my dashed
red so that's the contribution now the
weighted contribution of pc1pc2
add that back to the black mean curve
and you get this maroon function so it
looks like right so that for positive
pc one negative pc2
it has a
higher uh or it's pulled away it's above
the mean curve it's sort of the decay is
is slower compared to the mean
do this again
all the past results are going to be
grayed out but now see our points uh
over here at a sort sort of negative pc
one and roughly zero pc2
so now we see that
that shape which we'd expect right that
as pc1 got negative the decay at the
beginning was was greater it was quicker
steeper
so matches what we expect and we can
keep doing this again
and say a hundred times
and what we see is basically now
the those scores
when we constrain them just the basic
box constraints minimum and maximum from
our sample
we can actually get an idea of what
would all possible
functional observations for
maybe new materials that we might want
to explore so we can we can get an idea
of what are the all possible shapes
that we might want to explore now let's
think about this a little bit more
now if we have
so think of functional experimental
design right you you would say
if my factor is functional observation
it's really hard to define what is my
you know my low value
for my factor so my minimum my maximum
maybe like mid points in traditional
experimental design
but now i can convert that with fpca to
scores to get my two scores right two
scalar values that i can define
highs and lows i mean we've already sort
of explored that so actually if you try
to do
functional experimental design
jump has a platform that does this
and it will actually this is what's
happening in the background is it's
using a functional pca to redefine
scores to alter your shapes for defining
functional factors in doe
all right back to
back to the analysis part so how do we
answer our question right remember we
had the pc scores in two dimensions so
again the typical approach we just say
okay k means clustering i picked four
um
first component is 96 and a half percent
of our total variation so it's no
surprise that um basically it's just
four
or three vertical lines to separate the
four clusters our standard falls within
green and we kind of see the colored
overlays here
um and so to find the three closest just
let me think i just did the euclidean
distance
between all the points and the standard
and picked the top three they're all in
the green cluster and i think it's
pretty pretty cool picture here to show
the raw data so back to the discrete
samples that were measured at the very
first uh the first picture
that black and
the three green are extremely similar
um and so you know it might seem like uh
i'd encourage anyone interested to to
look at the code because basically once
you have
the functional object it's only
so smoothing plus pca plus clustering
it's only a few lines of well-defined
code it's a pretty easy workflow to
reach this result so i actually think
that this is uh
this is a
uh it was a probably quicker than if i i
tried to do some some of the uh the
other methods and trying to find
different moments that would capture
this shape appropriately
the last point on this is so
for the actual application that i
applied this uh at dao we similarly
selected
you know three
similar materials based on this approach
and i think it was also a nice result
that two out of those three were
experimentally validated when they did
more downstream work
uh so it was a also a very successful uh
project and really the first time that
it was applied
within dow at the time
so
i'll definitely pause there for
questions about fpca
let me go over to the slido
and i will just remind everybody again
if you just joined a little bit later
welcome you are able to ask questions
anonymously too or through the youtube
live chat so i'll just put the slido
link up there again as well
but one question that did come up a
little bit earlier was
specific fda problems can pop up in my
work and i'm not always sure which
analysis is right is there a recommended
resource for selecting approaches
yeah so
there is a reference slide so if you go
i'll probably pull it up but may not
talk about it uh when we get to it but
there's there's a series of three texts
um all by
slightly different authors but ramsay
and silverman are involved and they're
basically three different levels there's
one it's a really small springer book
about just
applications so all those examples that
i showed in the very beginning it'll say
here's a type of problem or a type of
data and here's how you would solve it
with
a functional
analysis method so and there some of
them are pretty creative too and so i
think you can i would start there
because that gives you you don't have to
know anything about the code that's the
second one in the series it's
how do you do this in r or matlab
and then the third one is the full book
which has all the math and the
derivations and theory so it's a very
easy read that's all basically like
here's an application and here's how we
might try and tackle it
so i think it's the um
well i guess
we could
skip to it real quick
uh so it's the applied it's the third
one on the list applied functional data
analysis
uh typo it's methods with a d and case
studies
i was trying to grow and grab that link
really quickly but i will
try and not do two things at once and do
it after um
let me go over to youtube and see what
questions we have there
as well
um
i know here's one question that was from
a little bit earlier too
could fda be used to describe
sales of a certain product family
i would say possibly i don't know if we
have enough
information so if product family is
defined as
so something like what i'm showing of
material characteristics where you have
a functional observation certainly you
could have
cost as an output i mean that's that's
something that's commonly used
for for evaluating
um
like
when you do an optimization of multiple
properties you could throw cost in
and say okay how is uh you know i want
to optimize these
application properties while minimizing
cost right that's a typical approach
but i think it's hard to answer
for sure without having okay where
where's the functional observation or
where's the functional
uh data in that
in that question
thank you
uh one other question that was on
youtube was
can you define functional as it is used
in the fda context
yes
simply that the
the underlying variable that you're
trying to analyze is a smooth continuous
function process curve distribution
so it's just it functional just refers
to the the type of of data that were
that we're analyzing it's the equivalent
of saying multivariate data analysis
where multivariate implies that you have
more than one variable being analyzed at
a time functional data analysis is you
have functional data and the methods
it's like the class of methods to
analyze functional data
curves distributions
processes are the usual just like a or
profile
awesome thank you i just thought of a
question here as well so
um for people who are
doing functional data analysis or
connecting with each other are there
like typical resources that you use like
are you on a slack group somewhere or is
there some community group somewhere
no um
at least not that i know of most of
like i say i had the one class and then
the
the list or the essential library of uh
textbooks out there is still
pretty small like the list that i share
of maybe seven
is is like maybe 75 percent of the ones
that i know about
so it's mostly uh self learning i do
know like some universities have
functional data analysis groups um but i
i don't actually follow the authors of
the text built the fda website that is
now defunct
so they tried to build a community but i
i don't think it uh it's it's not being
maintained anymore i think if you try to
visit it
so
unfortunately yeah it's it's uh
uh you know kind of self-learning
exploring and then as as new p as i meet
new people who maybe do it at dao uh
then it's
we kind of make a community there but
nothing
external for me
okay i will um
i'll ask john harman over at the r for
data science online learning community
slack if we can maybe just make a
channel for it there too so that
we have a place for people to go to
to connect i just put i
i love the slack channel um or slot
community so i'll put the i put the link
in the chat and then i'll try and pull
it up on the
screen here as well
it's good that teams decided to oh i
don't want to join teams decided to
disregard the fact i turned it off that
was nice
no worries here i just put that up um if
people want to check it out as well
and i think that's it for questions for
right now
yeah see well i see a couple
pop up here one about
fpca for
two variables or maybe two dimensions um
i'm sure
i haven't explored those problems myself
um but
so within the refund package i'd say
that's that's newer
and might tackle more i mean refund
stands for uh
well regression of functional data um
but
there
it also includes like
pc functional pc regression is another
approach that
okay this is fun
that
they might actually tackle it there too
so again i'd recommend because i haven't
done it myself that
some of the examples in those three
books that i that i talked about might
provide you some some background on how
you might handle two-dimensional or
multi-dimensional functional data type
problems
great i see a few more questions coming
in now too so let me pull them over to
the screen
which industries or sectors widely use
fda
that's a good question um
there is so i don't remember off the top
of my head but there is a
report maybe um
maybe rachel i'll go i'll find it and
maybe we can share it somehow with
everyone because it actually does it was
a it's like a systematic review of of
functional data
across all industries so they basically
a few years ago went back looked at all
the literature where functional data was
represented or referred to in keywords
and summarized it by
method uh industry
uh type of problem uh and and it was at
least
the only exhaustive list that i had
found uh up to
you know a few years ago like i say
so is there a way that we can get that
shared if i can absolutely yeah um if
you can find it after i could put it
with the recording as well so
this youtube live link will immediately
just become the recording right after
the session today and so i'll go and
update the details with information
all right
okay do you want me to hold a few more
questions until the end do you want to
take let's do that looking at that time
perfect
because i do want to cover the
functional regressions
topic
so
go back to my screen so i can progress
so before just like we did with
functional pca so what are different
types of functional regression it's not
as as straightforward as just uh
like linear uh regression in terms of
you can have
functions on either side or both of your
equation so the first scalar on function
you have a functional response and
scalar variable a single scalar in this
case as your input
i think it's easiest to look at in terms
of functional anova plus it shows
another analog
to
sorry
another analog to a traditional method
of just anova
so the equation looks very similar and
but you basically end up with a
an overall mean
function
mean
for your
across all of your
groups or your levels and then you'd
have a group specific contribution
that's also a function
so just to give you an example with that
canadian weather data again you could
look at the temperature or precipitation
profile as a function of
climate zone which you would expect that
right the the
contribution so compared to the mean
profile if you're in the arctic region
it's probably your contribution might be
some negative function to drop your
profile to be colder
for precipitation if you're in the
pacific it's probably wetter
for instance so it's looking at
your
zone
and trying to figure out what do the
profiles look like as a function of
of your
categorical input
next
is
function on scalar so just flip them so
now you have a functional input and a
scalar response
and this is what we're going to apply in
our situation here um and we'll see the
what the response looks like in a second
but i just always thought this equation
was interesting because it's like the
question first is how do you relate a
scalar in a function and so you actually
estimate a slope function which we'll
see
and this slope function is uh
represented as a basis expansion so you
actually use basis functions or basis
expansion all over again when you when
you actually fit this so what do we do
is we actually look at those
coefficients because the basis functions
are known
so the integral builds that relationship
to convert the profile to scalar so in
the example again it'd be
like predicting total precipitation
based on temperature profiles
more generally you could have function
on function so functions on both sides
now you'd actually have a slope surface
and the domains can be different they're
not they don't necessarily have to be
exactly the same of course it gets more
complex when they're different
and in the same example we now predict
the entire temperature prediction
profile from temperature profile
and last is principal components
regression but functional version
um so we'll actually see how we can use
the results from our
first exploration to predict our
property
but now what's interesting and quite
useful is right now it just becomes a
essentially multiple linear regression
in this for just a scalar response
because we have uncorrelated scores that
capture our variation so it really does
resemble what you do in regular uh
principle components regression
to set the stage uh
so the true slope function that i have
here uh is just
like proportional to square root of the
of time and the reason being is because
the in general this this property in the
application that we're looking to
uh predict the further
the curve is bounded away from zero the
slower the decay
the higher the this property value
so since they all start at the same
point relatively small to no
contribution at time zero
and you get a stronger a larger
contribution as this uh is further away
from zero and for in in
longer time
to so the responses are are simulated
again you all the codes available
and
i just use the true
uh exponential decay function so no
error plus the true slope function no
intercept term um and so this is how we
get to get the response
so i know i kind of leave a lot of i'll
leave out a lot of detail here but we'll
look at some more important i think or
more interesting comparisons in a second
but just this to give you an idea so
both of these perform similarly well so
we kind of expect that too it's
maybe we hope so because
we we capture nearly all the variability
in the system with the functional pca
so
let's compare these two quickly
the functional linear model i think one
of the big benefits is you do get an
estimate of that slope function
you don't do any dimension reduction so
you use the entire entire functional
observation
uh and pre-smoothing's not necessarily
always required depending on your inputs
within the the pfr function so that's
how you'd fit this within refund
now there are some cons degrees of
freedom because the slope function is a
basis expansion that you do have to
worry about if i use 10 basis functions
then that's 10 scalars that i'm
estimating 10 degrees of freedom
so it can get
you can in some cases require a lot of
data if you if you need a very extensive
uh basis expansion for that slope
function
sometimes the slope function may not
resemble the truth i'll kind of show an
example of that um
and and so i it may not be guaranteed
that you have a unique solution so it's
one that while you can get the estimate
it's uh you know maybe use it with a
uh with a grain of salt sometimes um
because you can also i've seen cases of
just having large standard errors of my
intercept which you get good predictive
performance but i think it tends to be
over fit in that case
so it just i i always recommend with the
functional linear model very careful um
exploration into
you know model stability and you know
standard errors and
typical things we might look at in uh
like a regression setting
and to show the example so i actually do
10 different seeds regenerate the
response and you can see the true
function slope function is red the solid
black is from the original model fit
and we get a bunch
of different lines with different slopes
with the gray lines so you see some are
steeper some are flatter and but you
also get some that are more quadratic so
they all have similar
maybe not exactly the same prediction
performance but it is possible that you
know you could get a shape that's
reasonable but
slightly different from the truth
in functional pca pcr
i it i think it's easier just from a
fitting standpoint and inversion because
we go back to just scalar scores so
which scores achieve a given property
and then we just apply that
expansion to get the
prediction
to get the
function
that is going to give us that predicted
response
and again
this is all just tied to
the
amount of variation explained so in this
case if we just looked at fpc one only
we do lose some prediction performance
but we're only losing three and a half
percent
if pc one was fifty percent pc2 was
thirty percent pc3 was ten
you would expect very different
performance if you just used
pc1 only compared to all three
and one thing to keep in mind
practically is if you do this approach
you basically need i would recommend all
the pcs for a given functional
observation or none because if you just
applied like model selection methods
what you'll end up seeing is that it
might just say oh you only need fpc2
well that's only three and a half out of
our 100
so you really need all of the of the you
know
more important pcs as well
so if you pick three use all three
all right i will in the interest of time
i will go to the second comparison
so just to compare to or just kind of
show
how i think functional question it can
be so powerful
scenarios where you have a very you have
more of a wide matrix so far more
columns than rows so in this case i only
picked i
simulated 10 materials
but now everything's measured at every
hour so it's a 10 by 25 matrix
we can apply various methods
so
i can compute moments like numerical
derivatives and just apply regression so
just rise over run either the entire
domain or subsections bins
i can look at area under the curve right
the larger that area the further from
zero it's a natural moment to pick
i can do just regular pc regression on
the data matrix
uh i can estimate say oh i think
exponential decay is appropriate here so
let's uh
let's estimate that parameter
then we know everything and just use
that as our moment and what you see
is compared to the functional methods
moment-based approaches we just lose too
much information typically
and even if multivariate approaches um
perform similarly we still lose that
functional relationship so i think this
is a powerful example to show that in
very data limited scenarios we actually
can
apply and use the entire function
in regression or like pca settings
so i see we're right at time i will just
leave the takeaways and further thoughts
up here
and
ask uh or happy to answer questions uh
rachel if you
are allowing this to extend i'm happy to
stay in chat if it needs to end uh i'll
let you make it yes you if you're able
to stay and chat with us that's awesome
yeah
great um yeah there's a few other
questions i know from a little bit
earlier
and one
was from santiago and i will say i
have learned a lot of acronyms through
speed up and googling but
between fpca then k-means on the pcs
versus functional clustering techniques
such such as fun femme which santiago
that sounds fun i've asked you what i
just asked what that means any thoughts
around how to choose between the two
approaches
yeah i have the same question i've not
seen
fun fed before
wish i could bring you on here but
unfortunately with reese this platform i
can't bring people on to chat yeah so i
guess that one uh
i'd have to look up or if you could send
in the chat what
even what uh fem there
uh stands for um
yeah so har i i can't i guess i answered
the question
yeah we could say that one for later
another question
was is there some sort of an overlay
between functional data analysis and
time series
yeah and so actually that gets to a
potential like takeaway here that i
didn't actually talk about when i was
covering smoothing but so
the data can be very related right you
look at we have
measured points over time in our case
study it looks like you could do
something with time series
however what that key limitation time
series is very rigid about needing
equally spaced points and if you have
multiple
uh different series that they have the
same number of points
um
what you could do is actually use
smoothing as uh like an imputation
approach or a way to convert
data like our case study which i i did
in an earlier step right i
smoothed all of them then i reevaluated
at every hour from 0 to 24.
so what did i essentially converted them
all to equally spaced and same number of
time points
so that's actually one approach that i
think can be used if you
uh
provided of course that the smoothing is
able to capture
the
like it's not such a complex time series
that uh you know this just a smoother
can't
give you reasonable estimates for where
you're trying to interpolate
but as long as it's reasonable i think
you could use
smoothing as a precursor to time series
because remember time series and fda
might actually solve different problems
too
so you know if you're looking at time
series to analyze you know stationarity
or seasonality that's a different type
of question being answered than like the
clustering or prediction in functional
data i'd use time series for forecasting
for instance there are
approaches you could do in
uh fda with forecasting but i think if i
could use time series i would
awesome thanks matt
um another question that was over on
slido
is have you tried your example with
traditional pca or pls
and can you just um
for everybody here just explain those
acronyms as well sure any comparison on
how fda performs better or worse
yeah so i think the big difference sorry
pcas principal components analysis and
pls is partial least squares the
difference between those two is uh pls
you you actually have a response or set
of responses so like pca is dimension
reduction on a data matrix that's
typically then like you you might not
have a response pls says i want to use
that i want to reduce dimension on the
input space reduce dimension on the
output space and relate those
two together um
the limitation of pls and it's actually
in a paper that compares these two it
does that example of
functional observations
say that you know column one is related
to column two to column three based on
that function right so if we did a data
matrix of decay we would see that the
values should decrease as you move left
to right in the table the columns are
all related in a specific fashion a
specific order that's the functional
piece of this
in pls or pca it doesn't care which
column is where you could just randomly
permute those columns just mix them all
up and you would get the exact same
model
so
the i think
you could see cases
so like for instance
if i go
into this the other example i was going
to share
here's an example where
principal components regression
act technically does outperform in terms
of
smaller prediction error than a
functional method however i would argue
that if i have functional data i would
actually want to use that information in
my analysis so even though pcr does
better i still gain way more
uh interpretation
actual like uh contextualizing the
solution the problem from fpcr and flm
than i would pcr
pcr being principal components
regression
i'm learning them
awesome thank you i just want to double
check were there any questions that i
have missed and
if so feel free to repost in the youtube
chat as well i don't see any others on
slido
let me just double check
and thank you so much matt
for sharing this with us and giving us
this introduction
this is it's very helpful and and really
fun to start to think of all the ways
that can be applied in in other
industries too
yeah i think that was you know
continuing the story another sort of
just
uh
happy coincidence was
there's just a lot of examples of
functional data within
plastics
and within the business where i was
working in and so
um
it was
lots of questions that needed to be
answered they and the team didn't know
how to do it and i was like hey i
learned this thing
this functional data
analysis set of methods i was like well
why not try it um and
that actually just led to more projects
more exploration and
um i mean that was simply just a meeting
with uh
as a new employee with a a senior fellow
who had some ideas and
just looked at the at the data and said
oh let's try something different and
just you know
the rest is history i guess
that's great
thank you so much and thanks for
reaching out after the first meetup you
came to and wanting to continue this
series on as well hopefully we can
find some way for everybody to connect
further to talk about this as well i did
reach out on the r for data science
online learning community too to see if
we could create a channel there
but you can also
connect with people through the meetup
recording which will auto will
automatically be on youtube and we'll
put all these helpful resources that
have been shared there as well
also just want to remind everybody if
you
are here today and are thinking about oh
i just learned this really cool thing or
i want to share a use case too i would
love to talk to you
and i'll
put my linkedin
in the chat right here if you just want
to reach out and say hello and
maybe share a few of your ideas we'd
love to meet you there too
but thank you so much matt really
appreciate your time today
thank you thanks everyone for for
joining
have a great rest of the day everybody
thanks for joining